ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen schön
dass ihr dabei seid auf Island ist in
der vergangenen Nacht ein Vulkan
ausgebrochen es sind spektakuläre Bilder
die uns von der Halbinsel reikanes im
Südwesten Islands erreichen gestern
abend um
22:17 Uhr Ortszeit schoss geschmolzenes
Gestein in die Luft Vulkanologen
sprechen beschreiben einen etwa 4 km
langen Riss im Boden aus dem pro Sekunde
100 bis 200 Kubikmeter Lavaströmen dem
Ausbruch ging eine wochenlange
erdbebenserie voraus das Schadensausmaß
ist bisher noch unklar ein nahliegender
Ort wurde bereits im November
evakuiert ja wir wollen heute fragen wie
ist die Lage jetzt gerade vor Ort welche
Gefahr geht von diesem Ausbruch aus und
wie reagieren die Menschen auf der
reanes Halbinsel darüber spreche ich
gleich mit einer Kolleg die in dem
betroffenen Ort aufgewachsen ist und
gerade auch in der Nähe des Vulkans ist
außerdem ist mir gleich unser ZDF
Korrespondent Henna Hebestreit
zugeschaltet der war kurzlich noch vor
Ort und ich spreche gleich mit dem
Vulkanologen Professor Ingo sass eure
Fragen und Gedanken zum Thema könnt ihr
wir immer sehr gerne direkt im Chat mit
uns teilen oder ihr schickt sie uns per
Mail an
zdfheute-live@zdf.de und ich versuche
dann so viele wie möglich hier im Stream
unterzubringen und an meine
Gesprächspartnerin
weiterzureichen wir wollen jetzt aber
erstmal nach Island schalten wie gesagt
zu meiner Kollegin Margret
palzdortier sie ist wie gesagt in dem
Ort grindawig ganz in der Nähe des
Vulkans aufgewachsen und viele ihrer
Verwandten leben noch dort und sie ist
mir jetzt zugeschaltet hallo Margaret
grüß dich du hörst mich hallo ja ich hö
hallo wir sehen du bist draußen
unterwegs es ist sehr windig bei dir
beschreib mir doch bitte einmal kurz wo
bist du da
gerade ich bin auf der Kreuzung von so
eigentlich zwischen dem Flughafen und
rewig so woh die Kreuzung unterweg nach
grinterwieg kommt so jetzt sehen sie den
Weg nach grinterwieg ich darf nicht
weiter und keiner darf hier weiter mhm
also die Straße nach grinderwieg das ist
der Ort der am nächsten dran ist an dem
Vulkan die ist
gesperrt wie ist die Situation
ich habe gerade schon gesagt du hast
Verwandte auch vor Ort erstmal wie weit
bist du noch vom Vulkan weg und wie ist
die Situation in dem Ort
gerade so die Straße ist 14 km weit weg
und ja soweit bin ich weg die Lage ist
da darf keiner ran weil das gefährlich
ist
und ja s nur Rettungsleute wir sind
nicht mal da man wartet hier und sieht
was daraus
WD die Lage da ist vi viele Häuser
zerstört oder einige und ganz and andere
gesunken gesunkener geich in die Erde
und einige Straßen sind völlig
okay ja und man wartet und weiß nicht
was was passiert ja margrat wir sehen
jetzt gerade auch parallel immer
Livebilder von Lava die da in den Himmel
schießt ähm Teile deiner Familie die
leben oder lebten in grinderwig wie geht
es denen jetzt gerade was was hörst du
von
denen ja sind ich weiß nicht äh so in
grinterwig wohnen knapp 4000 Menschen
und meine Familie das sind vielleicht 40
50 Leute ich weiß nicht wie viele sie
sind äh überall in Island eigentlich in
der Süd
und
ja wie geht's ihnen ist sehr schwierig
ist schwierig gewesen man weiß nicht was
ziert ist es ist seit 10 November dann
weiß man nicht was ist die wohnen hier
und da einige haben Sommerhäuser andere
W wohnen bei Verwandten andere bei Leute
die bei Leuten die die überhaupt nicht
kennen alle helfeninander das das Gute
was man fühlt und was man mitbekommt
die hatten gehofft ganz viele hatten
gehofft dass sie vor Weihnachten
wenigstens nach Hause für eine Stunde
oder so kommen können vielleicht über
Weihnachtszeit so wir feiern am 24 um 6
Uhr dann ist unsere heilige Zeit und
andere konnten sich das nicht vorstellen
aber jetzt weiß man dass es wird nicht
so we das wir anders ja Margret du sagst
jetzt es gab bei deinen Verwandten die
Hoffnung dass man vielleicht zumindest
kurz zu Weihnachten einmal in die Häuser
zurück kann bedeutet das dieser Ausbruch
jetzt gestern Abend der kam dann doch
für euch sehr überraschend
überraschend oder nicht äh man hat die
ganze Zeit gewusst dass es ausbrechen
könnte und es waren so verschiedene
Meinungen ob es so wird oder nicht so
die Spannung da in im Magma war so dass
man es eigentlich hätte sehen können und
die Wissenschaftler haben auch davor
gewarnt dann war es aber ruhiger
geworden aber man hat auch so in der
Erde gesehen es könnte passieren aber es
ist so wie es wie man kennt so einige
sagen ja es ist schon besser geworden
natürlich möchte ich nach Hause und
andere haben Angst gehabt und sagt nein
bitte warten wir länger und das hatten
wir gemacht und das wir hatten gehofft
oder
einige und aber muss man wusste
eigentlich nicht was man hoffen sollte
so ist es und so ist es und so war es
mhm Margret wie sah denn das Leben bevor
dann dort sich auch sozusagen bevor es
da die ersten Erdbeben gab bevor es erst
Anzeichen sozusagen auf eine starke
tektonische Aktivität gab wie sah das
Leben in
grenderwig vorher aus und welche
Hoffnung haben die Menschen dass es ja
wieder zu einer wie auch immer gearteten
Normalität dort kommen
könnte ja das ist ich sag ich sage ist
ist ein ruhiger tiischerdorf wie gesagt
mit 4000 Menschen immer mehr Menschen
ganz große Hoffnungen ist immer
mehr das sind fischfabricken und viele
andere äh Fabriken da und ganz viel
Tourismus auch nach den letzten
ausprüchen die da waren und sehr ruhig
schön so klein man konnte zu Fuß zur
Schule zur Arbeit einander
treffen und das hat man vielleicht nicht
so gewusst oder so mitbekommen bis man
bis die Leute woanders waren so wie z.B
reg Weg wo es ganz ganz viele Autos und
ganz ganz ganz anders und alle zerstreut
überall und wenn sie sich treffen
möchten oder zur Schule gehen s sind in
ganz vielen Schulen man versucht sie
zusammen zu zu sammeln inzwischen
täglich sogar und damit sie sich treffen
können und aber viel viel anders viel
mehr Stress und das kann kannte man
nicht und und das kennt man eigentlich
nicht hier in diesem friedlichen Dorf ja
wir hoffen dass es wieder so bleibt ihr
hofft dass es wieder so wird genau
vielleicht noch einmal abschließend wann
habt ihr denn gemerkt dass da was nicht
stimmt sie man jetzt so das war so eine
Stunde vor dem Ausbruch dann hat man
gesehen dass dann kamen viel viel mehr
Erdbeben aber dann war auch die Höhe vom
Land so gestiegen wie v vor dem den
großen Erdbeben am 10 November und dann
hat man auch als das angefangen hat
gestern abend dann hat man gewusst okay
jetzt passiert was so das war dann eine
Stunde vor und dann ist es plötzlich
dann ist plötzlich so wie
Sonnenaufgang hat man auf den auf den
Kameras gesehen plötzlich wie
Sonnenaufgang dann
ist der Vulkan ausgebrochen und hoch
gestiegen und ganz ganz schnell
unglaublich ja margr welche Hoffnung
habt ihr denn hat deine Familie dass ihr
vielleicht mal wieder zu Ort zurück in
den Ort
könnt das ist unterschiedlich Z das
einige so einige oder viele sie hoffen
dass sie dann wenn das vorbei ist dann
sie zurückgehen
knen gehen können andere können sich
nicht vorstellen da wieder hinzugehen
aber aber
äh auch sogar in in der selben Familie
aber es gibt
auch die meisten die sagen dann haben so
ein Sprichwort ich glaube und es gibt
gibt Lieder und ein neues Lied ich
glaube so ich glaube dass ich wieder
nach Hause komme und und ich persönlich
glaube dass ich diesen Weg f kann ich
wollte sogar heute oder morgen so mein
Dorf
besuchen und jetzt darf ich nicht weiter
als als das was ich jetzt kann so hier
stehe ich und ja ich konnte vielleicht
zu PUs aber das werde ich nicht machen
und man wird gewarnt das hoffen wir
hoffen ist eine Sache man natürlich wenn
das so schon ausgebrochen hat dann hat
man die Hoffnung dass es wie dass es
besser wird dass es so so ausgegangen
ist dann ist das es nicht mehr wird aber
dann weiß man auch dass es schon
angefangen hat das ist Nummer vier
Ausspruch Nummer vi und es könnte dann
mehr sein so es ist so wir wir hoffen
wir hoffen dass es jetzt
vorbei wird oder das ist irgendwie so
wird dass man es handeln kann ja Margrit
dann drücken wir dir die Daumen drücken
wir euch die Daumen vielen Dank für
deine Zeit und für die Eindrücke und
alles Gute nach Island danke schön danke
wir wollen später im Stream das auch
noch mal vertiefen welche Hoffnung es
denn jetzt gibt bzw welche Perspektiven
und wann sich dieser Ausbruch beruhigen
könnte darüber spreche ich im Laufe
dieses Streams noch mit einem
Vulkanologen ich habe es gerade schon
mal gesagt seit Wochen bebt die Erde in
der Region der Ausbruch war von vielen
befürchtet worden meine Kollegin sohat
kaldi die fasst euch einmal die
Ereignisse der letzten Wochen
zusammen glühende Fontänen schießen in
den Nachthimmel Lavafelder soweit das
Auge reicht wochenlang brodelte es jetzt
der Ausbruch die glühende Lava schießt
aus der Erde und bahnt sich ihren Weg
auf 4 km Länge zieht sich die glutspalte
der erdriss auf der rikanes Halbinsel im
Südwesten
Islands es ist ein Ausbruch mit Ansage
die erup hatte sich mit tausenden Beben
seit Wochen angekündigt gestern um 22:17
uh Ortzeit war es dann soweit und obwohl
unweit der Hauptstadt regjawig sind die
Behörden ernst aber gelassen Island ist
vorbereitet Island kennt das der
nahegelegene Ort grinderwig wurde
bereits im November gerollt der Gang zum
Vulkan untersagt aktuell gilt Alarmstufe
Rot unser ZF hen hierbestreit der war
vor wenigen Wochen vor Ort und ist mir
jetzt aus Kiel zugeschaltet hallo Henner
grüß
Dich hi also du warst 10 Tage dort
unterwegs wie hast du die Situation in
der Region
erlebt das war unheimlich spannend die
Leute waren sehr nervös sehr angefasst
wir hatten auch mit Margret zu tun die
eine Kollegin von uns die vor Ort und
unsere Arbeit unterstützt auch die war
wegen ihrer persön Nähe ihrer Herkunft
aus dem Ort sehr angefasst sehr nervös
und die ganze es war nicht auf diesen
einen Ort beschränkt die ganze Insel war
man hat so auf diese täglichen
Fernsehnachrichten auf die auf die
Pressekonferenzen des
Katastrophenschutzes geguckt und
gewartet weil jeder damit gerechnet
hatte nach diesen schweren Erdbeben die
es da Mitte November etwa am 10 November
gegeben hat und die am Ende dazu geführt
haben dass man diesen Ort grinnerwig
geräumt hat also alle Leute mussten binn
weniger Minuten die Stadt verlassen
und jeder hat wartet was passiert denn
jetzt es war zu sehen dass sich im
Untergrund etwas tat da gab es große
Risse im Boden wo sonst nichts also es
war war war normaler Ort wo die Leute zu
Fuß gegangen sind auf einmal war kreuz
und quer tiefe Risse 10 12 15 m tief und
viele Häuser waren durch die Erdbeben
beschädigt und die Leute waren völlig
paralysiert also
wer da gewohnt hat durfte dann immer mal
in Begleitung für wenige Minuten zurück
in sein Haus um das Notwendigste
rauszuholen das sind Haustiere gewesen
z.B die musste man damals zurück lassen
und man weiß das geht ja nicht lange gut
und deswegen sind die Leute
zurückgefahren konnten ihre Tiere holen
konnten ihre Pässe holen einige Leute
waren so schockiert dass sie in den
wenigen Minuten die sie in das Haus
konnten nur zusammengerafft haben was
sie irgendwie finden konnten wir haben
einen älteren Herrn getroffen der hatte
dann ein Bild in der Hand was wohl von
der Hochzeit seiner Eltern irgendwie war
und er sagt ich weiß auch gar nicht
warum ich das jetzt mitgenommen habe
aber das hing da und ähm also die
Menschen aus dem Ort waren wirklich äh
stark traumatisiert das kann man n so
sagen und auf der Insel her eine große
Spannung was passiert denn jetzt wir
selbst waren 10 Tage dort und
haben reichlich Geschichten von der
Gegend mitgebracht und auch im ZDF
gesendet
wir waren dann ganz froh dass nichts
passiert ist weil wir eben auch durch
viele drehvorhaben die wir vorher auch
in grinderwieg hatten viele Menschen
dort kennen und den wünscht man
natürlich nicht dass ihr Ort jetzt
irgendwie Opfer von so Vulkanausbruch
wird mhm du sagst die Leute hatten
teilweise nur wenige Minuten um da
irgendwie ihre habsäigkeiten aus den
Häusern zu holen hatten sie also gar
keine Chance sich irgendwie
vorzubereiten gab es keine Warnungen
vorher
sonst na ja es gab diese schwarmerdbeben
die sich über Wochen hingezogen haben
aber dieses etwa ein Viertel von Island
liegt im vulkanisch aktiven Gebiet wo
man immer damin rechnen kann dass
irgendwas passiert
und ich meine wer verlässt schon gern
sein Haus wenn er nicht unbedingt muss
also es waren viele Leute waren
tatsächlich für uns ich wir haben auch
eine Frau getroffen die gesagt hat ich
will da nie wieder hin zurück solche
Angst wie ich in meinem eigenen
vierwenden hatten hatte habe ich nie
wieder will ich auch nie wieder haben
ich hat gesagt wegen mir kann der Vulkan
das das Haus holen da steht man
natürlich dann so ein bisschen staunend
da und denkt sich upups ich hätte jetzt
mit ein anderen Antwort gerechnet aber
das kam wohl in der Heftigkeit und in
der Stärke auf der einen Seite sehr
überraschend auf der anderen Seite gab
es im Großraum dieser dieser Halbinsel
in den letzten 2 D Jahren insgesamt
schon drei Ausbrüche jetzt heute der
vierte und äh wir haben mit mit Ari
gutmon gesprochen der ist Geologe auf
Island und der sagte das passiert in
Wellen also etwa alle 6 700 Jahre gibt
es eine Phase der Aktivität die dauert
dann aber auch dummerweise 200 Jahre und
dann ist wieder Ruhe und er sieht oder
er geht davon aus dass die aktive Phase
jetzt begonnen hat und dass die Menschen
in der Region jetzt sehr lange auf
wackligigen terrin leben werden jetzt
ist auf Island ja gerade Hochsaison für
Touristen auch wegen der Polarlichter
welch wel Gefahren siehst du für den
Tourismus aktuell durch diesen
Vulkanausbruch direkte Gefahr überhaupt
nicht also es gab wohl kurz nach
Ausbruch heute Nacht Warnungen am
Flughafen von keflerwig das ist der
große internationale Airport auf der
Insel die wurden aber aufgehoben es
bestand immer so eine Gefahr wenn die
Lava z.B jetzt nicht an diesem Riss
hochgeht sondern ein bisschen weiter weg
im Wasser das ist dann zu großen
Dampfwolken kommt und das ist dann für
die Fliegerei auch gefährlich aber der
Flugverkehr geht Problem los weiter ähm
Island ist sehr gut darauf vorbereitet
die haben sehr guten Katastrophenschutz
schon als wir da waren war reichlich
abgesperrt da kann man sich auch nicht
durch Zufall in dieses Gebiet verirren
da stehen dann Leute selbst wir haben
das anderen zusammenhäng erlebt da bauen
ih Zelte hin stellen LKW irgendwie auf
die Straße und dann kommt da niemand
mehr durch und die lassen auch niemanden
mehr durch also da sind die schon sehr
sehr Gefahren
bewusst und ähm das Einzige was den
Tourismus in irgendeiner Art und Weise
tangieren könnte ist dass wenn 4000
Leute aus dem Ort evakuiert werden dann
müssen die irgendwo hin und man hat
viele in Hotels untergebracht in
Pensionen untergebracht und du hast es
gesagt auf Island ist gerade Hochsaison
wegen der Polarlichter da sind natürlich
die Unterkünfte auch gut voll und wenn
dann ein gewisser Prozentsatz an
Unterkünften Weg ist weil die Leute eben
irgendwo hin müssen die aus dem Ort
wegkamen weg mussten dann stehen die
natürlich nicht für den Tourismus zur
Verfügung ich sehe das hier die ganze
Zeit auch bei Youtube bei Facebook wir
bekommen von euch viele fragen wie es
denn mit dem Flugverkehr jetzt weiter
geht mein Kollege her hierbestreit sagt
jetzt gerade aktuell keine Auswirkung ob
das in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen so
bleibt das wollen wir gleich auch noch
mal mit einem Geologen klären welche
Auswirkung er da möglicherweise noch
sieht Henna an Dich abschließend noch
die
Frage welche Perspektiven siehst du denn
für diese Region ich meine es ist jetzt
für den Moment noch nicht absehbar wie
lange dieser Ausbruch noch andauern wird
aber siehst du da irgendwelche Hoffnung
für die Menschen dass sie irgendwann
zurückkehren
können ja das ist natürlich für die die
Betroffenen die eine Millionen Euro
Frage
als Journalist berichtet man ja eher
über das was passiert ist und weniger
über das was passieren kann
m was wir hören ist dass es jetzt eben
der der Anfang einer längeren Phase von
Aktivitäten ist in dem gesamten Bereich
da liegen ja auch viele touristische
Destinationen wie die Blaue Lagune da
liegt ein wichtiges
Geothermiekraftwerk was z.B die
Stromversorgung für den Flughafen und
auch für die ganze Region dort
sicherstellt ähm
das sind alles noch so wackelige
Positionen wo keiner genau weiß was mit
denen passieren wird aktuell sieht es so
aus als das hat auch gerade ein ein
isländischer Politiker im isländischen
Fernsehen gesagt sag wir mit blauen Auge
davon gekommen wenn es dabei bleibt und
die Aktivität im Moment geht sie wohl
schon wieder etwas zurück und spricht
von 10 Tagen die dieser Ausbruch dauern
kann aber die Hand dafür uns feuerlegen
will da auch niemand ähm be im letzten
Mal hat es mehrere Monate gedauert
also es gibt wohl Zeichen vorsichtigen
optimismuses jetzt für den kurzfristigen
Zeitraum aber wie gesagt wie das in den
nächsten Jahrzehnten dort aussieht die
Frage würde ich gerne den Kollegen aus
der Wissenschaft nachher
überlassen dann sage ich vielen Dank für
deine Einschätzung für den Moment danke
Herner Hebestreit nach Kiel danke schön
wir wollen die den Ausbruch und die
Auswirkung für die Region und für is
jetzt noch mal besser verstehen bevor
ich jetzt gleich mit dem Geologen
Professor ingor sass spreche schauen wir
uns aber einmal bisschen genauer an was
bei einem solchen Ausbruch unter der
Erde
passiert die Insel ist die größte und
aktivste vulkanregion Europas denn
Island liegt auf zwei riesigen
Erdplatten der nordamerikanischen und
der Eurasischen Platte die beiden
driftten 2 cm pro Jahr auseinander dort
hat sich der mittelatlantische Rücken
gebildet am Meeresgrund durchquert aber
auch Land genau an der jetzt bedrohten
Halbinsel rejanes die Erdkruste ist hier
eher dünn sodass an dieser Naht das
Magma schneller aus dem Erdinneren nach
oben drücken kann ganz Island ist so
entstanden Erdbeben zeugen von den
Aktivitäten da unten und immer wieder
kommt es zu
vulkanusbrüchen und aus Potzdam ist mir
jetzt Professor ingor sass zugeschaltet
er ist Geologe am deutschen
Geoforschungszentrum hallo grüße
Sie
grüße Sie also wir haben es gehört 100
bis zu 100 Kubikmeter Lava pro Sekunde
ein langer Riss der sich da durch die
Erde zieht kam dieser Ausbruch in seiner
Heftigkeit für sie
überraschend ja wie in ihren Beiträgen
die vorangegangen sind ja auch schon
mehrfach dargestellt wurde ist der
Ausbruch an sich keine Überraschung er
war erwartet worden er hat sich
angekündigt über ganz verschiedene
Kennwerte der konkrete Zeitpunkt ist
dann immer etwas
überraschend und auch die genaue Lage
des des ausbruchzentrums und so weiter
war in so nicht vorhersagbar also man
konnte zwar die Region vorhersagen oder
den Bereich aber nicht genau den Ort der
Magma
Produktion wir bekommen dazu die ganze
Zeit auch Fragen bei Youtube und eine
lautet wie groß ist denn die Gefahr dass
die aufgebrochene Spalte weiter größer
wird wie würden sie das
Einschätzen ja gut das ist ja ähm wie
auch eben schon erklärt äh im Prinzip
repräsentiert diese Spalte die
Plattengrenze zwischen europäischer und
amerikanischer Platte das geht natürlich
durch den ganzen Atlantik weiter und die
sind immer durch sogenannte senkrecht
dazustehenden transformstörungen also so
versatzeinheiten getrennt und
normalerweise geht so ein
spaltenausbruch bis an die nächste
querversatzeinheit ran und das wird ist
hier ähm in relativ guter Regelmäßigkeit
der Fall und äh zurzeit äh gibt es wenig
das darauf hinweist dass ein weiterer
spaltenbereich hier in Größenordnung
erfasst wird von dem Ausbruch also es
wird sich äh möglicherweise im
Wesentlichen äh bei diesem dieser
ausbruchsbreite
äh ähm ähm bleiben ja mhm bei den
Ausbrüchen in den vergangenen Jahren und
auch den Erdbeben waren ja bisher immer
hauptsächlich unbewohnte Gebiete
betroffen das ist dieses Mal anders was
bedeutet das konkret für für die
Menschen vor
Ort ja also die die Ausbrüche des des
torbion Vulkan in letzter Zeit die waren
ja jetzt durchaus auch sehr nah also
auch in der gleichen Nähe zu grinderwig
aber das ist natürlich eine eine
punktuelle Eruption gewesen aus
verschiedenen Gründen im Untergrund und
das ist auch eine relativ ruhige
Eruption gewesen die sich auch
angekündigt hat durch seismische
Aktivität hier war jetzt die
Besonderheit dass durch die Gelände die
durch das Füllen der magmaakammer der
magmenkammern entstanden ist der Ort
grinderwig betroffen war und damit eben
bewohntes Gebiet was ich eben zum Glück
nicht bewahrheitet hat ist dass hier der
Ausbruch unmittelbaren der Ortslage
stattgefunden
hat jetzt haben wir gerade von meinem
Kollegen Herner hebelestreit auch schon
gehört dass die Aktivität des Vulkans
seit gestern Abend zwar etwas nachlässt
daran würde ich gerne eine Frage
anschließen die wir von virena Jos bei
Facebook bekommen haben wie lange wird
dieser Vulkan denn aktiv bleiben also
lässt diese Meldung dass die Aktivität
jetzt gerade etwas zurück geht
ein Aufschluss darüber zu ja wie lange
er noch aktiv
bleibt ja ich also das können wir
natürlich nicht sagen
und wir sind hier in Potsdam haben
natürlich nicht die ganz aktuellen
Beobachtung der isländischen Kollegen
vor Ort die das dann konkreter
beurteilen können grundsätzlich können
solche Spal Ausbrüche also es gab in den
end 70er Jahren im Nordosten Islands
einen der fast anderthalb Jahre aktiv
war können so eine intermittierende
Aktivität haben das heißt die Aktivität
kann Absinken sie kann dann auch wieder
steigen
das wird man dann eben aus dem Verlauf
der Eruption ableiten also das kann sich
um ein wochenlange Aktivität handeln
aber hier ist durch die starke Abnahme
der Aktivität in relativ kurzer Zeit
kann man schon davon ausgehen dass es
bald äh etwas ruhiger werden wird aber
da ist nicht äh mit eingeschlossen dass
es dann auch ruhig bleibt mhm vielleicht
noch einmal kurz die Frage wie gut sie
sagen jetzt sie sind natürlich Stück
weit weg aber wie gut lassen sich solche
Ausbrüche denn überhaupt generell
Vorhersagen ja es gibt natürlich ganz
unterschiedliche vulkanusbrüche äh noch
mal dieser Ausbruch ist natürlich für
die äh Personen vor Ort
hat natürlich Gefahren etc p okay aber
er stellt jetzt so keine globale
Gefährdung da
und
diese Ausbrüche
na jetzt habe ich doch den Faden
verloren also diese Ausbrüche sind in
ihrer ganzen in ihrem ganzen Ablauf
ähm relativ ruhig relativ
wenig explosiv also was heißt relativ
wenig sie sind nicht explosiv es treten
gasexhalationen aus die sind auch
gefährlich und toxisch es treten große
Temperatur äh Sprünge auf es treten
weitere geländebewegung und Verschiebung
auf die auch in weitere Entfernung von
dem spaltenus Ausbruch da sein können
aber wir haben hier können hier nicht
von einer Aktivität reden die irgendwie
auser Kontrolle geraten ist natürlich
hat der Mensch keine Kontrolle über so
einen Ausbruch aber er ist auch dem was
dort passiert nicht hilflos ausgeliefert
das zeigen ja die Evakuierung die
bedauerlichen im Vorfeld und auch jetzt
die Sicherheits Maßnahmen im Umfeld des
Ausbruches die die vorangegangenen
Ausbrüche waren ja zum Teil
Touristenattraktion da ist ja durch die
Annäherung der Touristen an das an die
an den Lavafluss beim torbenvulkan
sind ja teilweise auch gefährliche
Situationen
entstanden die letzten Jahre waren ja
gekennzeichnet durch sehr viel ja
Aktivität tektonische architekturch
tektonische Aktivität so ist es richtig
wenn wir einmal den Blick nach vorne
richten was wäre ihre Prognose wie wird
es in den nächsten Monaten in den
nächsten Jahren auf Island
weitergehen also grundsätzlich ist ä das
eine besonders aktive Region und
ähm auch das war ja in ihren
anderen Beiträgen schon entsprechend
dargestellt ähm möglicherweise ist dies
der Beginn einer längeren
aktivitätsperiode die dann aber auch
auch unter menschlichen Zeitvorstellung
durchaus von langen R Phasen geprägt
sein kann also das können auch auch
Zehner 20er Jahre sein die dazwischen
liegen das wird eben auch ein
schwieriger Teil der Entscheidung sein
ob man grinderwig sozusagen wieder
besiedeln kann und wird und soll oder ob
man tatsächlich den Ort weiterhin
nicht wieder betritt oder besiedelt das
ist im Moment glaube ich schwer
vorherzusagen ich kann jetzt aus
isländischer Erfahrung eigentlich nur
das Beispiel aus dem Nordosten bringen
eben e aus dem krappler Feld
bei
akurairi
dort hat es eben nach einem Monate über
ein Jahr wähenen spaltenausbruch eine
enorme industrielle Aktivität gegeben
dort steht eine der größten
geothermischen Stromanlagen des Landes
und auch in der Welt und
das ist hier die Frage ob man hier also
auch die Geothermie dann
weiterentwickelt also dass hier die
Region verloren ist durch die
Vulkanausbrüche würde ich nicht sehen
man ist es in Island gewohnt mit diesen
Dingen zu leben und letztendlich sind
diese spaltenausbrüche also Ausbrüche
diesen Typs hier sind ähm einigermaßen
vernünftig prognostizierbar nicht im
Bereich von Tagen aber wie man jetzt ja
gesehen hat im Bereich von Wochen
Monaten äh durchaus vernünftig äh
natürlich waren die Gefährdung in
grinderwieg äh sehr sehr groß für die
Leute also auch Unfallgefahr durch
Geländesprünge und anderes es gibt ja
viele sekundärrisiken bei so etwas
rechtfertigen sicherlich die Evakuierung
des Ortes her s wir erinnern uns das
vielleicht abschließend noch an ein sehr
massiven vulkanusbruch auf Island 2010
ich sehen Sie es mir nach ich würde mich
jetzt gerne darum drücken diesen Namen
noch mal auszusprechen mit E
so ja danke sie können es natürlich
besser als ich damals gab es heftige
Auswirkungen für den Flugverkehr wir
bekommen dazu auch Fragen bei Youtube
unter anderem von Tim salabim wird der
Flugverkehr einträchtigt werden in den
nächsten Wochen in den nächsten Monaten
sehen Sie die Gefahr
äh nein also der eierfjaller jöul dort
ist durch den Ausbruch
an dem hohen Berg
das Gletschereis schlagartig geschmolzen
und ist quasi in die magmammer geraten
und dann explosionsartig mit dem
ganzen drumhum umgebenenden Gestein
herausgeschleudert worden was als Asche
eben in die Atmosphäre getragen wird das
diese Gefahr ist hier nicht zu sehen
selbst größere wasserdampfsäulen durch
Kontakt von Lava oder auch einem
spaltenbruch in Seenähe würden nicht zu
derartigen überregionalen Behinderung
führen also das ist nicht zu befürchten
sagt Professor Ingo sass Geologe am
deutschen Geoforschungszentrum in
Potzdam vielen Dank für Ihre
Einschätzung und für ihre Zeit heute
danke
schön ja herzlichen Dank und dazu
vielleicht noch ein kleiner Kommentar
den wir bei Youtube bekommen haben ich
weiß nicht warum aber ich will jetzt
auch ein roten Rollkragenpullover das
war natürlich jetzt ein lustiger Zufall
dass wir beide entsprechend hier so
eingekleidet waren ja soweit unser ZDF
heute live zum vulkanusbruch auf Island
aktuelle Infos aktuelle Bilder findet
ihr dazu wie immer in unserer ZDF heute
App danke fürs zuschauen danke für eure
Fragen und bis zum nächsten
Mal